okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p we
received a voicemail that is interesting
it's about veterans and the left i
disagree with the premise of the
voicemail but let's listen to it first
and then I'll tell you what I think
hey David this is change from at Ventura
tried to get you on the call line and
didn't but I wanted to ask you this
question because I think it means a lot
will the left never meaningfully accept
veterans and their families under the
big tent I'd ask you to consider at
least for the sake of argument the
veterans are among the most class
conscious and class organized groups in
this country look at Team Rubicon in red
white and blue the to charity work and
disaster prevention and all of the
organizations that support veterans this
accepting of military veterans under the
big tent would also help in taking the
corporate Dems and the corporate
Republicans ability to wrap themselves
in the flag you know out of that I want
to be part of the solution for my
country not part of the problem and I
definitely don't feel like the direction
that you represent and other people are
representing our part of the solution
not part of the problem how do we clear
the barrier can we I've asked you to
consider the bonus march and cement the
gutters or is the racket thank you very
much for your time listen I disagree
with the premise okay I agree that the
right has won the propaganda war around
supporting the troops but the left does
accept veterans the left is listen it's
not patriotic to say let's send our
troops all over the place to spread
democracy or whatever that's not that's
not patriotic and it's not supporting
the veterans when the left says we
really should be considering use of the
military as our last resort we shouldn't
use the military for political fights we
shouldn't use the military in ways that
we are putting them in harm's way for
the personal political priorities of
whoever's in the White House that is
supporting the troops when we say hey
the veterans are coming back and they're
not getting the care that they need and
there's PTSD and there's other things
and we've got to fund that properly
that's patriotic that supports the
veterans that supports the troops when
Trump says there's lots of veterans who
just aren't strong enough so they have
PTSD
right that does not support the troops
that does not support veterans so I
reject wholeheartedly the idea that
veterans and their families are not
accepted by the left it's that the right
has and it may even have infected this
collar the right has so successfully run
the propaganda war around the troops
that you end up getting calls like this
where someone says hey it would be
really great if the left accepted
veterans what exactly are you talking
about when you say that because I
consider my views on troops and veterans
of the most Pro troop and Pro veteran
views one can have they just aren't use
our troops for political gain around the
world indefinitely increase funding to
unnecessarily cartoonish levels to
endlessly buy and replace more and more
weapons that will never be used and that
we don't need that doesn't seem to
support the troops that doesn't seem to
support veterans I'm actually for
supporting the troops and veterans in
the ways that I would prioritize number
one keeping them safe and number two
keeping them healthy and number three
jobs programs and reintegration into
society after serving overseas etc etc
etc so give me a break
the left has no problem with veterans
but we have unfortunately lost the
propaganda war in great part to
messaging from the right around support
the troops sad very very sad on today's
bonus show we will talk about yet
another threat to the affordable care
act I will also talk about Netflix
making an announcement that they are
going to try to pare down in Netflix
original programming the amount of
smoking of cigarettes that takes place
because of complaints that at this point
in time we should really stop quote
glorifying smoking by having lead
characters and others smoke cigarettes
in shows very interesting topic which I
want to get into on the bonus show and
lastly nearly a quarter of Americans now
say they do not believe they will ever
retire according to a new poll we will
talk about the details of that as well
as the economic implications and the
socio-cultural implications get access
to the bonus show instantly by becoming
a member at join pakman.com or becoming
a patron at patreon.com slash david
pakman show